[Music]  another year is looking good on Kourtney  Kardashian babe the reality star just  turned 39 and to celebrate strip down to  nothing but her birthday suit for a sexy  photo shoot with V Magazine that's the  mom of three posing naked with a bright  pink jacket draped over her right  shoulder and booty there's just too much  going on hot mama port celebrated her  birthday on Thursday night with her  famous family and closest gal pals we  really had the best time ever  naturally her younger sister Kim  captured the festivities on snapchat  including momager Kris Jenner Stokes so  you taught me how to be a mom you taught  me how to love you taught me what being  a mom was all about and you were the  first you were there first  an epic dance party  the birthday girls multiple birthday  cakes and even a makeout sesh with Kim  and her hubby Kanye West  [Music]